yes well my hat size no I do not know my
head size I don't wear off I don't wear
hats but I wear beanies
I've been wearing yeah I knew wear hats
a little bit when I beat you in tennis
you've never beaten me BAM
what are you doing this is absurd
[Music]
you have to communicate contextually and
creatively in these channels where these
humans now live I love how people keep
saying this is coming like I just I
always get such a kick out of that
because this is just it's happened you
know the data is so black and white
there's a reason 97% of consumer
packaged goods are declining it's
because they're over allocating in trade
FS eyes television Direct Mail you know
it's just so black print it's just so
black and white that it's almost I
almost feel like I'm in that movie the
big short and I'm the guy with the glass
eye I'm like the fundamentals are
obvious yo what up Instagram we're about
to draw thank you so much when do we do
it cyber monday Black Friday Tuesday
Saturdays anyway doing the drawing 5 and
you were gonna join me for dinner in New
York what's gonna happen alex is gonna
get all the winners and then coordinate
with all 5 I'll send it all the way out
to like April Oh am i flying them out
here yeah I did all right
flying out the five of you to New York
for dinner now for everybody goes to
know what the [ __ ] is going on on Black
Friday weekend Cyber Monday weekend I
did a giveaway give me crushing it real
quick I'm gonna do another one right now
right so we're gonna do a breakfast
version of this this is the thinner
version I'll get to in a minute where do
we send the receipts to ok we're gonna
start a new one called 10 copies at
vaynermedia com
Andy can you have somebody set up ten
copies at vaynermedia com you got that
d-roc oh you rock and do things like
that
do you rock good [ __ ] anyway get ready
for buddies watching 10 copies at
vaynermedia com
you weren't part of the 5 it cost you
less to do the dinner then the breakfast
that shall have [ __ ] works way to lunch
at 40 copies at vaynermedia calm but
right now 5 copies if you bought it so
for example this person's to be sad I'm
gonna pull this one out right now you
did not win there's gonna be a
heartbreaking moment for this person for
example bill James he could have won but
he didn't you did not win but Phil
bought five copies and so he got in here
once but other people bought 10 copies
and LEM over here LEM did his job he's
not only good at finding Darren Lee
jerseys he's also good at if you bought
20 copies four of your receipts came in
here five of you getting flown out to
have dinner with me together
can't wait to do it's gonna be a great
podcast it's gonna be a great piece of
content and all of you will be buying
crushing it all of you all of earth I'm
gonna pull out five people right now and
the five Phil James I'm sorry the first
person joining me for dinner in New York
somewhere in the spring is an out some
just gonna give these to you right on
the spot okay you're just filming you're
not part of the content Tyler here we go
is is can you help me here that you
don't have the name like what is that
what you wrote that yeah yeah yeah but
what's the person's first name Sean he's
a real bad guy he's probably getting
fired guys breaking news lives been
fired let's just send him right to HR
all right I've got news for you it's in
the UK Oh got chopped off yeah
not your fault Labs congratulations
canner in the UK you're the first
[ __ ] UK right off the bat it's like
these Becks war better be in London so
we could just do it another canner
congrats person number two now remember
for all of you that are live started for
people you have to edit a little bit max
you just leave it five copies on one day
you send in the receipts to five copies
at the intermedia now I'm pulling it
dinner with me probably in New York but
maybe now London and we're about to do
another one in a second you guys did not
miss out no FOMO if you want to
breakfast with me and five others it's
gonna be ten copies gonna keep going up
breakfast Oh
afternoon tea right it's gonna be like
80 copies number two is David hutchinson
in San Bernardino California we're off
to a tough start location wise person
number three to have dinner with Nate's
there's gonna be epic - I'm gonna teach
you everything about life and make you
forty three billion dollars that's a
good trade for five copies you rock you
rock have you set up ten copies at
vaynermedia comm third person for this
one is Erik Algar in San Diego
California all right - in California
right now person number four I got it
it's jarn den pura bond
congratulations I have no idea where
you're from but it looks like it's in
u.s. dollars the lands home and the
final person in the
first dinner series the breakfast series
coming up next in C Health Hipple
congratulations to the five winners and
that's that oh let's whoo let's pick one
person who would have been a winner if I
was doing six people
just for a little razz just so you can
make the joke with your friends the
first person that lost is Levi mcCormick
sorry Levi hey everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 376 of
the askgaryvee show this is the Friday
before Christmas so the office is in
that perfect zone I love the fact that
so many of you are traveling right now
and you're at home out of office replies
that scale is always when I'm most
comfortable because when the world is
not working I am actually calm it
evolved different than our conversations
we really thought and we still will do
this we want to activate for a lot of
clients a lot of clients spend too much
money no different than commercials and
banner ads you know we're always looking
for where's money being overspent in the
reality of the world we live in and we
feel a lot of clients the biggest brands
in the world when they're at Superbowl
when you're not the NBA Finals and
all-star weekend and and the Kentucky
Derby and CES spend a lot of money to do
booths or mail-in things that we think
there's an opportunity to do better we
specially then think that there's
something incredible around the culture
of activating that is instagram-worthy
and this how digital and social work
with real life but we thought that
that's what was gonna be the core yeah
and then we would sprinkle at some time
wouldn't it be cool if we created our
own thing whether it's a South by
Southwest or a Coachella and obviously
I'm using the biggest a big but we'll do
our own things but in true Gary and Kim
fashion like in four seconds for like
you know let's launch our own conference
and that's how agent 2020 how did the
engine 20 21 how is that actually born I
mean that was the theory but like what
did happen good I like sucks you in the
middle night or probably yeah I mean it
was just an emoji maybe a smiley face
with dollar signs coming no I think like
vaynermedia as a whole in you obviously
if
a ton of inbound requests just in terms
of these four industries there's a huge
gap between how they're marketing their
businesses and where consumer attention
is the four industries are travel agents
insurance agents car dealerships and
real estate agents where you get a
chance to tell me how great you are or
it is or that is you eat somebody's
attention what eliminates the real
estate agents of the moment their lack
of innovation you DM the person in shape
I own a car dealership I'd like to pay
you to show up at my car dealership this
Saturday from 12:00 to 4:00 and you tell
your Instagram followers I had somebody
who's done over a million dollars in
revenue in the insurance space doing
only content and advertising only
through Facebook every hotel company
should have gotten together and then
bought residential and then created in
the Airbnb competitor the startup tech
world now reminds me a lot of real
estate now that I've been in it because
the real estate industry has cycles when
it's so good that losers win I think
it's a really good idea for every
dealership here to buy the twenty
thousand mile radius around the
forecloses high school your deal
[Music]
can I love you all right everybody have
a great great great holiday season I
hope you enjoy this episode hope we see
a bunch of you in Miami hit up kpop and
at Boehner experience if you've got
questions they've been incredible on
that and we will see you you keep asking
questions we will keep answering them
how did you what happened how did you
find my stuff you can get legacy men in
their 20s they're there in their most
insecure state looking for to scratch a
lot of short-term itches and you know
and you get into bad habits and and I
mean [ __ ] man I didn't even have my 20s
I worked at my dad's liquor store it day
and night I did nothing I did more fun
stuff last night by going to the Knicks
game yeah you went to very good yeah
and just yeah it's fun when the gardens
buzzing so you're super excited about
the World Cup the culture in the sport
is you have to do one thing just speak
your truth
you're when I look so Anthony you know
this Instagram is the place right
Instagram is the place so when I look at
your Instagram right you know you have
such an interesting mix right like that
father-son thing that's smart so for
example let's just look at the
difference between my account and your
account you'll find this interesting
right these are subtle things that I
don't talk about a lot yeah he's happy
right now
but like look here's my profile it's got
four long lines of data it's got this
new Instagram stories where you can the
highlights you can put it in there where
I can really tell my
story right like your goal your you
scored in the World Cup like that cup
that clip should be right here my World
Cup goal right whereas in your account
like all it guide is God as my god is
amazing but you have four more lines
it's only link to your Twitter you know
little things like it's okay to like
it's not bragging when it's a truth how
old were you when you scored your World
Cup goal nineteen you know it might be
something interesting I do like the fact
that you've got the mix of the of the
football content and the personal
content right like I do think that's
good but I also think a little less
polish right so I think the biggest
thing celebrities in their space need to
do is have once in a while just really
raw like everybody wants to incident to
look so perfect you just said smartly
the kids of my generation we're not
sharing our problems because everybody's
living their PRD life on Instagram if
you look at people's lives on Instagram
everybody's p-diddy I think one of the
things that has been really strong for
me is I don't need my content to be
polished like some of it is some of it
isn't
it's the biggest lesson for these guys
right like they came in and like they
want to make great content great content
is the truth not the lighting if you're
such a thoughtful young man I'm getting
that sense so quickly instead of you
know when you have a thought just going
into the camera I'm just saying hey
everybody like this is my thought
especially with what swear he just told
me would be amazing that second day when
you're down in that league like now I've
time to think I used to say lots of
smart [ __ ] like good content is the
truth not the lighting and it was lost
in space but now babban super excited
because gonna make that one-minute video
you know what I mean like like to me
here's something that I think is always
packed powerful about athletes you know
that classic Nike like commercial where
it's like you guys see me scoring a girl
goal in the World Cup when I'm 19 but
you're not seeing me the day I got
injured
that looked me right like you see it
went fast for me it's I think that's why
what I'm doing is so powerful I'm
documenting the journey
and everything changed when I started
the vlog two years ago because all of a
sudden when I would talk about hustle
and hard work
it's so obvious in their face and look
what today is you know like it's you
know it's two days before Christmas
three days before Christmas the city
shut down but who's in my office
my team that's just the truth look
either and by the way I don't I don't
think you know I don't think this is
right like I'm I'm thrilled that 95
percent of my company is with their
family right now and they should be and
I can't wait a couple more hours and
next two weeks I'm out but the truth is
the truth is the truth is the truth and
like I think I think I'm very excited
because I think we're going through a
phase right now where everybody's trying
to show the best but we've always done
that
your grandparents in Kenya when they
went outside something bad was happening
in the house but when they went outside
and had a coffee nine and ten times so
we I hate when people like social media
you know I keep saying it's exposing us
not like oh now people are learning that
we always put up facades and we don't
have real conversations but we were
doing that for years when all the old
Russian men used to go and play checkers
outside in Russia like maybe if they
drank a couple vodkas they [ __ ] on
what's going on at home but like most
people especially immigrants you know
what happens in the house right 100% man
in my household like not like every
single bad thing that happened to my
family that I saw with my eyes and I can
remember from 6 to 18 died in those
[ __ ] four walls you went outside
isn't so when people like Oh everybody
shows the best version of themselves
where PR and we're not sharing we never
[ __ ] share you understand so if you
have the ability and the power to share
well then you owe it at stake so you
need to know yourself before that's
right and you're young my man listen
I'll tell you right now and this is what
I always want to say I'm glad you said
that because it allows me to say to the
vlog I have the benefit of the Internet
coming around when I was over
man now there's a lot of me that wishes
I could see them this was happening when
I was 22 cuz I [ __ ] had five like
like it would've been amazing to do a
vlog that look the same every day for
nine years me in a liquor store for 15
[ __ ] hours day because then everybody
be like whoa like I love them people
like I did I'm like go on YouTube and
look at that pisode one of Wine Library
TV to a thousand there's a thousand wine
videos cuz that's what business like
Reuben we're like you could see nobody
was watching so it's cool man
that makes me happy that you want to
share like that you should but don't be
fancy and if you need to use snapchat
and Instagram stories because that's
what people doing they're willing to be
less fancy they're everybody's put the
Instagram feed on a pedestal mistake I
love aesthetics I understand design
mistake anyway people didn't post today
cuz they have a pimple that was my
generation - was it a hundred percent
there's a people are [ __ ] on
Millennials as if they didn't twenty
years ago I'm not I was supposed to [ __ ]
without as it either if we just didn't
have it so we didn't go out that Friday
night lost got it it's just documented
now that's all nothing's changed here's
the thing every young person on this
earth needs to become grateful no matter
how bad their situation is because they
have the power of this to get them the
[ __ ] out that's [ __ ] huge it's bigger
than big I get emails Tyler would tell
you use my mics from homeless people
because they have smart phones so when I
hear some [ __ ] kid who's sad they're
like he doesn't like I'm like dude you
be any context of what's going on in the
world and you know this like a great
advantage you have is your heritage
coming from where you came from big
difference in your family came with a
big city in Kenya no they came from yeah
they come from a big city but
you have difficulty it's a hell of a lot
different in Paris like I've gotten
really not full circle but like the fact
that when I came to America we lived in
Queens and not the Queens that it is now
in a [ __ ] room the size of this
[ __ ] office multiple family members
the fact that I know that and remember
it oof I mean I'm so much tougher than
everybody like I can go to zero again
Hey like like when you can go to zero
again that's why I'm dangerous
I can go to zero again you're multi to
lose there's something I started
starting to have now I'm not doing it
for the my saw all the cars and
everything bottom line the thing that's
going to push you till the end and make
you a legend and influence this world
it's not the things that you see now
having a family stable family next to
you and wanting the right things and
that's that just changed my whole
perspective because now I go oh man
man good twenty two years old talking
like this you were so blessed
you know hardest Eastern Shore costs
don't know it yet they know it more he's
very smart
listen I know them cold right they know
it a lot more than they did before but
not all the way yet you can't you need
to get it they haven't been as lucky
soon maybe they didn't get it out of the
system yet Tyler definitely not you know
like sometimes I got you know like like
the bottom line is it's a big deal I
it's such an interesting observation I
sit here and I say have nothing to lose
and the person watching on YouTube right
now is like the [ __ ] he talking about
here's so much stuff I don't anything to
lose cuz the stuff is not what I'm
playing for
it's huge there's people who want to buy
a Viper or aerobics or like cool
sneakers or like like I I don't want to
buy sneakers I want to buy sneaker
companies flip them and win Super Bowls
and I don't even want that I just want
the chance to do it the game anyway man
you're a good dude
really nice to meet you let's let's stay
in touch
take a famous photo and get our
instagrams up I love the home and home
happy man real pleasure to eat bye guys
bye dear Rach I miss you I don't even
remember you anymore yeah oh one second
guys hold on hold on hold on one second
home once again see you blog in 2018
[Music]
[Music]